dans l'oeuf tout
profession preuve intellectuelle ça
change
surveillante grille tu touches à mes
affaires je te crève dignité de ce que
ça m'a fait mal au cou du fica qui
m'appellent pour me dire que ma mère est
très tôt leur est adrien rey de faire le
môme la cause d'un connard l'acta
complètement lobotomisés je peux plus
faire marche arrière
c'est vrai qu'on a tous été sacrifiés
pour qu'ils puissent échapper nous avait
permis l'évasion de votre mari en lui
fournissant une arme en main propre peut
donner complice d'homicide volontaire
la comédienne a menacé de mort je
changer de cellule bien sûr avec vue sur
la mer sur les jardins fouille des
cellules que vous conseiller de
collaborer avec la police
ses fans se sont pas des années c'est
toi qui a choisi de venir au présent
bertand faut actionner tu vas pas son
aversion t'attrape pas parce que tu es
une théorie soit une affaire talent
tiken irak